voici une femme vous allez l'avoir vécu
froid en arrivant au pays
bien sûr c'est cette jeune saoudienne
art à feu mohamed arkoun qui a passé sa
première nuit à toronto où elle a été
accueillie comme vous le voyez sur ces
images d'hier matin par la ministre
les affaires étrangères et christian
friedel c'est une femme qui avait attiré
l'attention du monde entier dans une
campagne twitter après avoir fui sa
famille en thaïlande
le canada lui a accordé l'asile pour en
parler je joue un référé de kerkhof
ambassadeur canadien à la retraite et
professeur à l'école supérieure
d'affaires publiques et internationales
à l'université d'ottawa
de kerchove bonjour bonjour tout d'abord
un mot sur la demande d'asile a été
examinée vraiment à la vitesse grand v
est-ce que c'est exceptionnel ce qui
s'est passé à votre avis ce n'est pas
exceptionnel mais ça paraît très
exceptionnel compte tenu de la vitesse à
laquelle cela a été fait mais si vous
voulez dans le cas d'un danger réel à
une personne on peut parfaitement le
blosne mangane bien peut parfaitement
décidé d'accélérer le processus
bien des ministres ont eu recours à
cette pratique je sais que monsieur
accès aux outils quand il était mon
ministre était particulièrement soucieux
notamment de ce qui se passait pour les
femmes au pakistan donc si vous voulez
cette dimension de la part d'un
gouvernement très féministe est tout à
fait normal mais c'est une vision très
accélérée qui pourrait entraîner
d'autres demandes et celle d'être sa
l'une des questions qui se posent à
l'avenir est ce que tout le monde toutes
les femmes en danger vont se servir des
médias sociaux
cela dit la procédure appliquée a été
respectée elle est tout à fait normal
évidemment le fait que la mini se
rendent elles mêmes pour accueillir le
musée lalique non c'est évident un
retrait très politique et c'est évident
un petit coup de pied de nez en vers
l'arabie saoudite ça c'est clair
et vous pensez que ça pourrait a créé un
précédent est ce qui s'est passé donc
d'autres personnes va utiliser à twitter
ou facebook pour pouvoir fuir une
situation quelconque 1 500 dangereuse
écoutez nous vivons dans une cycle dans
des situations tout à fait différente
les médias sociaux nous nous dominent
totalement et je n'exclus absolument pas
que d'autres le font c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs ce qui a fait un peu hésité
le ministère étrangères
australie qui eux ont une politique
peut-être un peu moins ouverte et moins
accueillante parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes dans le région qui sont plus
grands que leno mais c'est fort probable
qu'à l'avenir vous aurez d'autres cas
les mais ça ne veut pas dire non plus
que à l'avenir le canada va
nécessairement accepter tous les cas
comme cela ceci est un cas d'exception
un cas de véritable danger
un car en plus de sa impliquant un pays
avec qui nous avons pas mal de problème
donc autrement dit aïe aïe à tout nu une
espèce de conjoncture qui fait que nous
avons agi très rapidement mais il n'ya
rien d'excessif dans la procédure de la
procédure existe elle est là pour ça
dans un cas de danger hop on embarque
quelqu'un le plus rapidement possible
dans un avion surtout à la demande
united a donc si vous voulez tout ça et
réglementaire mais il y a un côté
politique indigne à une question quand
même préoccupante ces sacs sécurité
maintenant elle qui avait reçu des
menaces de mort elle a même dû fermer
son compte twitter pendant un moment son
père et son frère se perd en thaïlande
pour aller à tenter de la chercher et
quelle est la responsabilité maintenant
du canada concernant sa protection
vous remarquez qu elle est dans une
résidence où il ya une sécurité 24
heures sur 24 à l'heure actuelle
précisément en raison de ses inquiétudes
que l'on a
quelles sont les responsabilités elles
sont les responsabilités d'un
gouvernement à l'égard de tous ses
citoyens qu'ils soient immigrants qu'ils
soient réfugiés qu'ils soient canadiens
de longue date dont 90 ça ne change rien
sauf que effectivement la police le
large en dames et royal va s'assurer
qu'une protection et s est assuré pour
cette personne jusqu'à ce qu'on ne
craignent plus mais compte tenu du fait
que nous faisons face à un pays qui n'a
pas hésité à dépecer un journaliste
rendez compte qu'à une inquiétude vous
avez aussi le co ne le côté de l'aspo
stasi ou même l ain cannon a dit qu'elle
renonce à l'islam
est-ce que c'est qu'on fait mais est-ce
qu'elle va le faire mais il est évident
que dans ce contexte là le danger est
absolument réelle même si elle est au
canada on ne sait jamais quel élu berlue
toutacoo déciderait de faire justice au
nom de l'islam
arnon d'un fanatisme alors que l'islam
n'appelle absolument pas ce genre de
comportement mais vous savez qu'il ya eu
des dérives épouvantable moi je au
pakistan je me souviens très bien avoir
vécu le cas
deux sets de 7 jeunes face cette part
dans cette jeune femme assassinée dans
les bureaux de la protectrice des droits
de la personne au pakistan asma jong-il
sur l'ordre de son père et de sa mère ça
a été fait par le chauffeur nous vivons
dans un monde de fous et il faut donc
prendre des mesures en conséquence c'est
la sécurité de ce jeune femme elle s est
une cité c'est une question réelle et
sur lequel il va falloir continuer à
regarder certains que les corps
policiers feront de leur travail comme
il faut alors prendre les mesures en
conséquence vous voulez dire est qu'il
faudrait justement à quel une protection
policière pour pour moi ce sont son
début de vie ici au canada
écouter eric comme je le dis elle est
déjà dans une résidence qui est un
studio ou la protection la sécurité des
24 heures sur 24
et je crois qu'on va faire en sorte de
2,2 de surveiller effectivement d'un
autre côté il faut garder la liberté
cette personne là mais je suis certain
que les tables des coûte serons en
marche pour s'assurer de que que l'on ne
que l'on puisse déceler des actes
criminels
mais rien n'est garanti à 100% mais je
suis certain qu'on va veiller sur elle
parce que nous ne nous sommes inquiet
des pommes à cause de la situation que
qui est créé ça c'est indéniable ans il
va y avoir une surveillance laquelle je
ne sais pas parce que je ne suis pas
dans ce domaine là mais c'est certain
qu'il y aura une surveillance qui se
rassurer et en terminant cette affaire
comme est ce que vous êtes préoccupé par
l'impact de cette décision du canada
concernant les relations avec l'arabie
saoudite gérer au point où on en est et
je crois que les relations étant ce
qu'elles sont la seule chose j'ai
exprimé tresseur mon inquiétude est ce
que les saoudiens vont se ranger sur
monsieur badaoui à cause de ce l'on a
fait ce qu'ils sont capables de faire ça
est-ce qu'on va renouer les coups de
fouet je m'excuse mais avec ce qui se
passe un arabie saoudite et meurent à
mettre ben salman je n'exclus aucune
possibilité mais je crois que d'un autre
côté la fac à sotchi a suffisamment fait
de tort au régime saoudien pour que
peut-être de la mort de monsieur catchy
permettent peut-être une meilleure une
meilleure réaction méchant je le peux je
peux assurer de rien je ne peux rien
vous garantir parce que nous faisons
face à un pays qui nous a qui a pris des
mesures tellement dilatoire un autre à
notre regard qu ça et tout est possible
mais cela dit les contrats continuent en
ce qui concerne
ils ont tout n'est pas terminé ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que ça se termine
rapidement et que l'on retrouve des
relations normales avec l'arabie
saoudite
mais ça va prendre autant de temps que
ça prend pour l'arabie saoudite de se
calmer avec le qatar avait nouveaux
auxquels ils ont imposé un blocus avec
trois autres pays donc foulé la
situation internationale avec l'arabie
saoudite n'est pas tonnes et ce n'est
pas cette affaire qui va changer ça
profondément mais c'est un autre pied de
nez que nous avons asséné à l'arabie
saoudite et ils sont certainement pas
content pendant pas mal de temps
merci pour votre analyse ce matin ferry
de kerkhof merci d'avoir été là